hallo ihr lieben ganz ruhig ganz ruhig
ihr habt am titel schon gelesen wir
machen heute schoss ich weiß wie
verrückt ihr danach seid denn ich bin
selber verrückt danach und nicht gehen
nie an einem stand vorbei ohne mit
chamrousse mitzunehmen
aber jetzt lüfte ich das geheimnis wie
einfach das ganze zu hause machen können
und dafür bereit mit zuerst ein brand
teig zu den haben wir schon mal gezeigt
zeigt jetzt aber gerne noch mal und
hielt die zutaten dafür benötigen wir
wasser
außerdem butter mehl und eine prise salz
so um den brand tag jetzt herzustellen
braucht ihr einen topf da geben wir die
butter und das wasser rein lassen das
schmelzen und einmal aufkochen und dann
geht es weiter
futter und wasser sind am köcheln
und jetzt gehen wir noch prise salz
fragen das runde ding geschmack ein
bisschen und dann das mailen einen schon
mit dazugeben und anschließend richtig
gut abbrennen lassen am topp ich zeige
euch gleich was ich damit meine
und nimmt dafür kein schneebesen sondern
einen kochlöffel
[Musik]
sobald ihr das medien so gibt werdet ihr
merken dass ich ganz schnell ein
teigklumpen bildet und dann brennt ihr
diesen teigklumpen am topf ab dann
entsteht so eine kruste macht sich auch
keine sorgen das geht ganz leicht ab
aber sie können den topf ganz leicht
reinigen und so bald nichts mehr geht
das dauert so um die zwei minuten geben
wir diesen teil klumpen in unserer
schüsse und das in ungefähr fünf bis
acht minuten lang abkühlen
[Musik]
und die masse ist jetzt etwas abgekühlt
das ist ganz wichtig damit die eier
nicht stoppen wenn sonst riecht und
schmeckt nach höhe und das möchten wir
nicht und das jetzt immer eine
küchenmaschine gegeben es geht auch mit
dem kochlöffel nimmt nur kein
schneebesen mit dem kochlöffel ist es
ein bisschen mühsam es ist ein kraftakt
das gebe ich zu aber das kriegt ihr auch
hin
aber falls ihr eine küchenmaschine habt
dann nehmt eure haken und dann hat es
alles ein bisschen einfach ich werde
jetzt erstmal anschließend auf mittlere
stufe ungefähr dann werde ich
nacheinander die eier 1 drin also immer
wenn alles eingeführtes nächste
reingehen
[Musik]
sobald die eier vollständig im teig
verarbeitet sind ist auch schon fertig
ich zeige euch aber mal ganz kurz damit
ihr euch zu hause nicht erschreckt dass
er wirklich sehr klebrig ist also man
erkennt hier schon und jetzt fühle mich
einfach um dafür habe ich mir schon mein
spritzbeutel mit einer spritze
bereitgelegt das hier ist eine stelle
die hat einen durchmesser von 1 cm und
breiter will ich es auch nicht machen
und habt ihr so richtig dicke groß ist
auch lecker aber so werden wir eben
richtig schön knusprig für das kurz ein
und dann zeige ich euch wie es
weitergeht
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich hier meine frittiert
station aufgebaut das heißt ein topf mit
ausreichend frittierfett sodass es also
komplett rein passt schon und dann habe
ich das ganze einmal erhitzt und ihr
erkennt dass es so weit ist wenn eben an
einem holzstab oder an einem holz
kochlöffel hier solche kleinen bisschen
aufsteigen so und was ihr jetzt noch
benötigt dass es auch sehr wichtig ist
eine küchen schere
denn damit schneiden wir gleich den
schoko ab und ihr könnt selber
entscheiden wie lange das ganze sein
soll
[Musik]
so ich mache das jetzt komplett fertig
und falls ihr euch fragt wie lange das
ganze dauert also bei mir dauert zwei
bis allerhöchstens drei minuten schaut
einfach besser richtig schön goldbraun
sind
[Musik]
und wie bei allen zitierten sachen geben
wir das zuallererst auf einem küchentuch
dann kann das fed so ein bisschen
abtropfen und dann werden wir das im
zimt zucker aber ich habe auch keinen
kleinen geheimtipp für euch zeige ich
euch nachher
[Musik]
also mein geheimtipp folgen wir wälzen
dass er in zimt zucker ist super lecker
ja aber jetzt passend zur jahreszeit
tausche ich stimmt aus gegen spekulation
gehört super lecker oder einfach rein
und dann verrühren hamburg richtig
lecker und jetzt fehlt den tourbus nur
noch an geschmack und das ist auch der
grund warum wir kein zucker in den brand
teil getan haben denn der kommt jetzt
zum einsatz setzen jetzt in sotschi russ
im zimt zucker oder spekulatius zucker
könnte übrigens auch im kalten zustand
machen aber es muss nicht sofort
erfolgen und den rest dann werde ich
ganz einfach nutella genießen das duftet
schon richtig richtig gut
und fertigen unsere shows total lecker
weil selbst gemacht natürlich und ich
bin ganz ehrlich ich gehe nie an einem
toro stand vorbei ohne meditrust zu
können
zu jener maßen hanser kopf dem anklamer
von dem wie immer genau aber jetzt mache
ich sie gerne zu hause ich frittieren
ich oft aber wenn dann muss ich auch
richtig jungen das lohnt sich für die
shows und jetzt probiere ich einmal so
lecker geschnitten richtig frisch und
das gute ist außen knusprig und innen
schön das allerwichtigste so ich habe
euch die genauen mengenangaben und die
infobox
ihr könnt main kanal gern kostenlos
abonnieren mir ein dörfchen nach oben da
lassen und ich freue mich wie immer auf
eure fotos mit dem hashtag description
auf instagram dann sag ich bis zum
nächsten häufig skizzen tschüss gesagt
[Musik]
das ist alles meins sowie für alle fragt
wann kommt das video online war kurz
rezept ich muss immer genießen genießen
dann kann ich mal gucken weil ich das
video schneider immer gucken beschreibt
noch kraft habe weil ich so fett werden